und noch ein beleg werden jetzt wirklich
alle thesen zur dunklen materie
umgeschmissen
es gibt nämlich einen neuen beleg für
die spektakuläre these dass die dunkle
materie nichts anderes als schwarze
löcher ist ein neu entdeckter quasi
widerspricht allen gängigen theorien und
damit ist er ein erneuter hinweis dass
es viel mehr schwarze löcher gibt als
bisher angenommen und sie die dunkle
materie bilden klicks und salzgitter
ging es drei mal pro woche spannende
science videos abonniert den kanal und
aktiviert die glocke nur so verpasst ihr
nichts los gehen herzlich willkommen es
handelt sich eindeutig um einen neuen
rekordhalter und der gibt der fachwelt
super spannende rätsel auf denn nun
aufgespürte quasi die unglaubliche 13,03
milliarden lichtjahre von der erde
entfernt bislang gibt es keinen anderen
quasi der unserem heimatplaneten noch
ferner ist rekord der gigant wurde von
den fachleuten auf die bezeichnung york
03 13 18 06 getauft zu sehen ist er für
die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler in einem zustand der ihn
lediglich 670 millionen jahre nach der
entstehung des universums zeigt im
klartext bedeutet das in diesem quartal
gab es bereits 670 millionen jahre nach
dem urknall eine zeit zu der das
universum erst fünf prozent seines
jetzigen alters erreicht hatte und
dennoch der rätselhafte gigant war schon
zu dieser zeit ein unerklärlicher riese
sein schwarzes loch umfasst nämlich
unglaubliche 1,6 milliarden sonnenmassen
damit weiß es die doppelte masse des
bisherigen rekordhalters auf auch hier
also rekord und dieses schwarze loch mit
seinem extremen leuchten stellt die
fachleute vor große rätsel denn diese
gewaltige masse widerspricht allen
gängigen theorien die großen fragen
lauten also wie gelang es dem quasi so
viel masse in solch einer kurzen
zeitspanne anzusammeln und allgemein
formuliert die können solche masse
giganten überhaupt kurz nach dem urknall
entstehen und wenn sie es tun gibt es
viel mehr schwarze löcher und bilden sie
die dunkle materie die unglaubliche
entdeckung gelang dem us forschungsteam
von
diverse theorie so nah mit dem 6,5 meter
teleskop des lask kampagne stop signs in
chile genauer ins visier nahmen die
fachleute in den giganten dann noch mit
weiteren teleskopen die weltweit ihren
platz haben mit dabei unter anderem auch
das gemini north stream auf hawaii und
das genießt haus in chile so kam das
forschungsteam zu extrem spannenden
effekt demnach strahlt das 1,6
milliarden sonnenmassen schwere schwarze
loch achtung ca 1000 mal so hell wie das
gesamte milch straßensystem die
unglaubliche entfernung des basars
konnten die fachleute mit hilfe der
kosmologischen rotverschiebung
analysieren da diese als ein maß für die
entfernung auf für das alter solche
objekte dient sie liegt bei diesem quasi
beim wert von z gleich 7,6 4 2 hier gilt
die regel je höher die rotverschiebung
umso weiter entfernt und desto älter ist
das himmelsobjekt so kam die us
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
also zu dem spektakulären ergebnis die
galaxie von j 03 13 18 06 befindet sich
bei ca 13,0 3 milliarden lichtjahren und
zwar in einem alter von nur 6 170
millionen jahre nach dem urknall und
genau solche schwarzen löcher kann es
eigentlich nicht geben wenn ja wenn man
die bisherigen theorien zur bildung von
schwarzen löchern annimmt bilden sich
schwarze löcher also ganz anders oder
zumindest eine erhebliche wenn nicht
gigantische zahl
das hätte erhebliche konsequenzen schon
vor längerer zeit hatten forschende
quattara als interessante
forschungsobjekte entdeckt 1960 hatten
forschungsteams rätselhafte radio
quellen am himmel aufgespürt die genau
wie sterne radiowellen ins all schicken
doch es konnte sich nicht um sterne
handeln denn dafür waren sie viel zu
weit weg das was die signale aussandte
war also entweder extrem nicht schwach
oder aber unsichtbar 1962 hatte man dann
bessere instrumente am start und den
forschungsteams gelang es doch etwas zu
erkennen also doch schwach leuchtende
sterne jedenfalls unvorstellbar weit weg
von uns das licht hatte mehrere
milliarden jahre zu unserer erde
gebracht und so konnte es sich eben
eigentlich nicht um einen stern handeln
denn diesen hätte man aus solch einer
entfernung gar nicht sehen können ein
riesiges rätsel
für astronomen und astronomen weltweit
fest stand zumindest schon mal ihren
namen getauft hatte man die kosmische
objekte quasi abgeleitet also quasi
stellar also quasi ein stern
es nahm noch einige zeit in anspruch bis
bessere teleskope entwickelt worden
waren
die dann endlich die auflösung des
rätsels mit sich brachten quasare sind
die kerne von galaxien supermassereiche
schwarze löcher die besonders viel radio
strahlung aussenden die galaxie strahlt
am himmel also so hell wie ein stern ist
es aber nicht das klingt jetzt ein
bisschen paradox ein helles schwarzes
loch es strahlt nicht selbst sondern die
materie die in diesen schwarzen löcher
stürzt kreis vorher wie wasser in einem
strudel bevor es in das schwarze loch
fällt dabei entsteht eine extrem starke
reibung und die gase sternen und
planeten brocken heizen sich auf und
leuchten erst ganze 36 jahre nach der
entdeckung konnte eine wirtz galaxien
der quasare fotografiert werden das
gelang dem weltraumteleskop hubble und
machte somit noch einmal deutlicher dass
es sich bei den kosmischen objekten um
die hellen kerne von galaxien handelt
theoretischen physikerinnen und physiker
erkannten schnell dass die unfassbare
leuchtkraft der quasare nicht mit der
thermonuklearen fusion wie sie im stern
inneren abläuft zu erklären ist sondern
eben mit dem material strudel um das
schwarze loch der akkretionsscheibe doch
trotz intensiver forschung stellen
fassade die fachwelt weiterhin vor
rätsel
denn den gängigen theorien zufolge
entstehen supermassereiche schwarze
löcher dadurch dass sie mit der zeit
immer mehr gas und umliegende sterne
verstehen bei der supernova explosion
massereicher sterne könnte demnach deren
vorläufer entstehen möglicherweise sind
auch die verschmelzung solcher vorläufer
wichtig für das wachstum
supermassereiche schwarze löcher eine
sache ist jedenfalls klar
all diese prozesse brauchen zeit und
immer mehr entdeckte schwarze löcher
hatten diese zeit nicht ein anderer
mechanismus muss sie entstehen lassen
haben
denn manche der äußerst massereichen
schwarzen löcher im inneren von pasanen
stammen aus
der frühesten anfangszeit des kosmos
manche sind eben sogar mehr als 13
milliarden jahre alt dabei müssten sie
doch nicht nur zu wenig zeit sondern
auch viel zu wenig futter zur verfügung
gehabt haben um zu solchen extremen
größe heranzuwachsen
denn fachleute sind sich sicher dass
sich sterne erst rund 100 millionen
jahre nach dem urknall entwickelt haben
die schwarzen löcher die wiederum aus
ihnen entstanden sind waren wohl viel zu
klein um sich direkt zu einem basar zu
entwickeln dazu sagt der wissenschaftler
fey gewann der bei der aktuellen studie
mitgemacht hat schwarze löcher die aus
den ersten massereichen sternen
hervorgegangen sind können eigentlich
nicht innerhalb weniger hundert
millionen jahre so groß geworden sein
wie also konnte dieser quasi zu seiner
gewaltigen masse kommen dass astronomie
team hat sich dieser frage ausführlich
gewidmet und ist zu extrem spannenden
ergebnissen gekommen
den berechnungen der
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
zufolge muss bereits der vorgänger des
schwarzen lochs rund 100 millionen jahre
nach dem urknall entstanden sein und
bereits damals musste dieses
unglaubliche 10 tausend sonnenmassen
erfasst haben und auch hier ist klar
diese ausgangs masse widerspricht allen
gängigen theorien
sie ist weder mit dem wachstum durch das
verstehen von sternen zu vereinbaren
noch mit den schwarzen löchern als
vorgängern dazu der astronom chf an der
an der studie beteiligt war
diese werte sagen uns dass der keimling
dieses schwarzen lochs durch einen
anderen mechanismus gebildet worden sein
muss denn so früh nach dem urknall gab
es schlicht nicht genügend sterne um den
vorgänger des quasars ausreichend zu
füttern
auch die verschmelzung kleiner schwarzer
löcher schließen die fachleute eindeutig
aus denn für diesen prozess blieb nicht
genügend zeit stattdessen halten sie es
für möglich dass das schwarze loch durch
einen kollaps entstanden sein könnte und
zwar der kollaps einer dichten wolke
primor idealen wasserstoff gases wobei
das gas extrem stark komprimiert wurde
der begriff primor die ahl wird übrigens
von dem lateinischen wort für
ursprünglich abgeleitet so könnte sich
also ein schwarzes loch im zentrum der
wolke gebildet haben
zu diesen möglichen erklärungen satz
schreibt das forschungsteam nur in einem
solchen szenario lässt die rechts und
kollapses könnte so früh
vorgänger objekt von mindestens 10.000
sonnenmassen entstanden seien und diese
annahme ändert alles und führt uns
zurück zu professor günther hasinger
wissenschafts direktor bei der
europäischen weltraumorganisation esa
den wir hier auf pixum im
exklusiv-interview hatten für ihn zeigt
dass also es gibt einfach an
verschiedensten stellen phänomene die
wir uns nicht erklären können wo
schwarze löcher eine rolle spielen die
da sind wo es eigentlich nicht sein
sollten
und diese prima realen kosten daher
könnten das alles erklären er ist sogar
der ansicht dass solche schwarzen löcher
direkt nach dem urknall entstanden sind
dabei könnten schwarze löcher
verschiedenster größen entstanden sein
mini kleine löcher nur einige zentimeter
groß aber auch extrem große schwarze
löcher und dann wäre unser universum
voller schwarzer löcher es könnte mehr
als sterne geben und die dunkle materie
könnte ganz anders zusammengesetzt sein
als bisher angenommen
dunkle materie schwarzes loch in unserem
sonnensystem
das ist nämlich auch eine interessante
konsequenz ist der mysteriöse planet 9
ein schwarzes loch diese these vertritt
nämlich günther hasinger anklicken
anschauen und abonnieren und zwar diesen
kanal klicks um seinen flug
ich würde mich wirklich sehr über ein
abo freuen denn wir strengen uns echt
hier an spektakuläre themen einfach und
ausführlich zu erklären also bis dann
bleibt dran